qui n'a jamais connu de la ville du
robert dont elle est originaire aux
projecteurs de france 2
livia 16 ans ébloui de sa voix de
soprano
[Musique]
la jeune fille s'est distingué dans la
catégorie chant au milieu de seize
candidats dans une demi-finale aux
accents de noël la candidate est ce soir
téléspectatrice la première nommée et
les ja et de support sur scène c'est
impressionnant mais tu étais
impressionné déjà devant le public où tu
étais concentré
j'étais concentré mais sûrement au
regard d'abord oui j'avoue je me
regardais pas parce que j'entends déjà
les personnages de me dit il j'ai fait
une numéro là et voilà mais c'était bien
oui j'ai beaucoup aimé depuis le temps
que je suis avec elle j'ai l'impression
que c'est quelqu'un de nouveau
d'ailleurs il me fait découvrir des
visages nouveaux des personnes nouvelles
ni livia ni ses parents n'auraient
imaginé vivre pareille aventure
commencée il ya tout juste un an avec
son inscription puis sa victoire au
concours les voix de l'outre-mer un
événement créé par fabrice di falco le
chanteur d'opéra aujourd'hui c'est en
tant que coach qui le suit livia entre
cours de chant et mis en confiance
le coach vocal c'est le coach personnel
jacques au dessus de la voie c'est un
coach aussi pour la rassurer et pour
qu'elle puisse montrer son talent au
milieu et elle nous a éblouis
livia chante depuis l'âge de 3 ans
aujourd'hui il s'agit de donner le
meilleur de soi dans un registre musical
nouveau
j'écoute beaucoup de bien c'est j'écoute
car diby j'écoute du zouk compas soca
j'écoute de tout vraiment tout et
maintenant tu écoutes à peu cet opéra
maintenant oui
d'avancé je n'écoutais pas du tout je
suis fière d'elle encore plus parce que
marque invite tous à ma fille elle garde
les pieds sur terre
c'est une personne qui reste humble une
prodige la vni en tout tracé elle
souhaite être sage femme et poursuivre
ses cours de chant au conservatoire en
attendant c'est dans la salle de
l'atrium que livia ravira les amateurs
d'opéra un concert gratuit demain soir à
20 heures
il